all right all right all right we are
back and we have jeff booth with us
let's pull jeff up real quick
jeff how are you
great and good to see you pam absolutely
great to see you as well um before we
get started maybe let's just remind
folks you have a great framework of
looking at legacy uh inflation deflation
uh kind of intersecting with technology
forces so maybe just remind everyone
kind of how you view uh the macro
structure the market structure of
inflation and deflation
um sure we're going through phase
transition in markets
and things won't look the same on the
other side of that um and it's driven by
technology technology is um
exponentially trying to reduce cost
and it's moving faster and faster into
everything around us
we vote our time with things that get
cheaper and more effective so we vote
for things that give us more value
yet the market is designed the exact
opposite way market is designed to make
prices rise forever
and so that credit based system that we
live in that we measure everything by
housing everything else is is is up
against a new reality that central
bankers don't understand and so or if
they understand that there's nothing
they can do about it
because technology wants to
essentially give us more for lust and
that's the opposite way of our the way
our financial systems are designed when
you think about a great example of
technology trying to give us more for
less is there one or two examples that
you're like okay this is a great way for
people to wrap their head around that
idea
well look at your phone like
and look at everything on your phone
right the
um you look at your camera on your phone
look at we don't pay for uh
photographs anymore we get abundance
billions of photos trillions of photos
that are free
we used to pay for a distribution
network for photography take a couple
photos and say and develop them a month
later and say oh those were wrong
today we get that abundance for free i
mean it's not just phones it's music
it's not just
photos it's music it's every everything
on your phone so look at every app on
your phone and it's a perfect example
but there's many others why do you think
why do you use google how do you use
amazon why do you use all of these why
do you use all these services because
they give you more for less on a
compounding or exponential scale
when you think about
kind of the central bank actions i think
it was very clear to folks hey whenever
there is some sort of market downturn
or some sort of economic crisis they
basically have two tools right they've
got the ability to manipulate interest
rates they've got the ability to
leverage quantitative easing or the
creation of money and then there's
obviously fiscal tools that could be
used as well
now that we are called 18 months or so
uh from the official end of the covid um
recession so not talking about the
health crisis but the economic crisis
itself um what's your general take on
the actions that were taken and then
kind of where we find ourselves today
um
general take is uh and and and this
might surprise a bunch of people on your
show but my general take is
um that the fed and rest of central
banks around the world are trapped um
they they cannot stop
so if you if you allowed
deflation to take place today
on a credit based system
you would have an unwind of epic
proportions every bank would fail every
institution would fail and you would
have
you would have societal collapse
on the other side and so when you see
um and and so now
that doesn't change the fact
that technology is making is trying to
drive more for less
it just changes the fact that we're too
late to save the existing system
and so so the facts are
technology wants to give a make our time
more valuable why do you use technology
why do you think every business uses
technology
and the facts are also that the existing
system can't allow that to happen
so they're trying to stop that by but
and
because they they're worried about the
depression and what that would look like
so they're trapped in and
trying to
essentially reduce
the real burden of the debt and create
and all sorts of policy tools to try to
to drive inflation against that
um but what they're up against
is more likely or what could happen as a
credit collapse and and yes
because if they don't if they if they
actually stopped easing
you would have a credit collapse
and um and if they if they don't stop
easing you're going to have revolution
on the street that's uh
unfortunately when you have corruption
in the base layer of money
as a but and money is just a trade of
our time
then you must have corruption everywhere
in society as a result of that
corruption in the base layer of money
but
but and this is where
it's important
um they're trapped um
and and there's nothing they can do
about it because technology is a
stronger force in fact what would any
business do do if tech if labor is
getting more and more expensive in their
business
and consumers demand lower prices
they'll automate
what's so fascinating is this trade-off
of what i'll call short-term decisions
versus long-term decisions right so the
short-term decision of if we stop the um
kind of trend and the momentum of the
central bank activity uh and basically
stop easing the market
what you're saying is there would be
this credit collapse which would be um
you know pretty significant pretty swift
uh in kind of the history terms um and
be very very painful for a lot of people
the trade-off is you avoid that
short-term problem by basically
continuing the
game and you continue to ease you
continue to ease and you deal with the
problems later but the problems later
aren't credit collapse it's basically
this like revolution in the street that
you talked about and so is that a fair
kind of way to look at it it's not just
credit versus revolution but it's also
short-term versus long-term impact
absolutely it's but but again if you
just if you think about every single
business um and what they do typically
when they see technology
impacting their business is they
entrench further in their business so
blockbuster is a good example that i use
all the time blockbuster added candials
to their stores when all that changed is
download speeds uh went faster and all
of a sudden you could download a movie
and netflix took over
when that when that happened it rendered
the 9000 stores of blockbuster
irrelevant almost overnight but what did
they do
pretty standard operating procedure to
protect the legacy business
that framework is important because it's
exactly the same framework that central
banks are doing um in a in an economy
level at an economy level in our entire
monetary policy
and that and that is having cascading
consequences across society but it's
important to so it's not
i would say generally it's not bad
people
it's they people that don't understand
how fast technology is moving and what
that change means to an existing system
they just can't see it because the
system is designed differently in fact i
would say to a lot of your listeners
that they too
measure the system everything that i saw
a little bit of your segment before
we're measuring the in the system from
the system so we're measuring climate
change from a system that inflation
equals climate change inflate to you
can't grow forever on a finite planet or
grow goods forever on a finite planet
like they measure so you create more
monetary units to create more uh to
create more growth which is climate
change um when you think about that so
but again we get caught measuring a
system we measure house prices from that
same system and we don't ask the
question would host prices have gone up
if we didn't print if we didn't
um juice an economy by 185 trillion
dollars over 20 years so we don't again
we measure the system from the system so
it's really hard to see how a different
system could operate
one of the pieces uh that we spent a ton
of time talking about here
is what i call it the education gap but
the way that it manifests itself is uh
you essentially have this juicing of the
economy or the central bank activities
and there's a portion of the population
you know 50 to 60 percent of the
population uh that understands whether
directly or indirectly the best way to
benefit from this is to simply own
assets don't save all of your money in
cash
try to get some sort of job that they
increase the pay on an annual basis to
combat inflation etc but there's still
you know 40 to 50 percent of the country
uh specifically in the united states
they hold no investable assets and they
live paycheck to paycheck uh save
everything in dollars and they get
really hurt by this and so we get this
widening inequality gap you had this
tweet recently that basically was
talking about like the manipulation of
money
to ensure that prices continually rise
but basically it creates for the vast
portion of population this kind of
modern day slavery to a monetary system
like you can't get ahead right
everything keeps rising and costs around
you uh and you're just on that rat wheel
and you just can't get off talk a little
bit more about um you know is that a
feature of the system or is that more so
a bug that it's a way to have the kind
of fiat monetary system but not have
this specific negative impact
now so so remember
um and this is where i want to be
careful that that a system will
reinforce a system is so it's a way
bigger consequence and and and it's easy
to look at people in the system
instead of a system naturally
reinforcing a system i know it's the uh
and why that's important is
it is a feature of this uh system
inflation is theft it's a hidden theft
and that theft enriches some people at
the cost at the expense of other people
inflation as you said on your last
segment inflation the other side of the
coin is wage and savings deflation so
your real
the wages you're getting are going down
in real terms
and so when you have a small number of
people at the top
um and more people at the bottom and you
drive inflation you're hurting the
people at the bottom more and more and
more and you're enriching the people at
the top
what the people at the top don't see
though as well is
the societal collapse of that
creates kind of the next step of that in
us versus them and revolution comes so
if you look at uh if you look at germany
um in the 30s same thing was happening
and who do you think they're wealthy
were
and when what happens next is as a
revolutionary leader comes in
and changes the narrative to say we're
going to take back those assets
and and so
in that in environment and what ends up
happening with the wealthy in that
environment too is they think they're
safe because their assets are in hard
assets like real estate and everything
else but those real estates are in the
country
that is that is creating that
inflation
and those and because of what happens
next those assets are are
often seized or or or taken back
when you think about uh what people can
do
is it simply just buy assets like the
assets that will benefit from this hold
those assets for a long period of time
and that is the
kind of escape hatch for folks um or
does that not even work or how do you
think about like what can people do
about this
so
um
and and this is this is where i think
we'll get to bitcoin um and i think that
is the safest asset and it's an
asymmetric bad it's the safest assets
it's the king of all assets in this time
but more importantly than than that um
it's a vote of what you want the future
to look like you i think you i think you
either believe that uh that um
it's okay for a small number of people
to control all others
and and they can print money all they
want and everybody else is a slave
to that system
or
it's not um and if you believe that it
is okay uh for for that to happen
who should those people be um because
throughout time what people
throughout history
you see people changing their minds
um ego arrogance
humans are humans change their minds and
and i would do want i want to trust
monetary policy to people who change
their minds and create that
for um and if you kind of play that
forward where things are moving with ai
and robotics i don't want to concentrate
that power in a small number of people
to make decisions over everybody else i
would rather have that decentralized so
prices and what would happen on bitcoin
standard is prices would constantly come
down so it would enable the free market
so prices would so the abundance gained
from technology would be more broadly
distributed
yes it is the primary asset i would own
in today's market because of the safety
you can move it anywhere um and you're
not
so if you remember 12 words you can get
on a plane and go anywhere you want and
there's going to be countries competing
for for for capital and entrepreneurs
the same way they do now on a fiat
system they're going to be competing on
a bitcoin system
so that provides a relative safety for
family wealth gain and everything else
but more importantly
um because the system can't change
itself
you need a phase you need a transition
mechanism to allow you to get to the
other side from an inflationary monetary
policy which might have worked for a
long time
to one that allows deflation which must
be must work
which must be enabled with technology
with where technology is going
when you think about bitcoin
specifically why do you say that it's
superior to all of the other assets is
it uh something to do with the structure
of it is the sovereignty is it
everything in totality like how do you
think through the various options that
someone has maybe equities real estate
other commodities currencies and bitcoin
well let's let's look at uh
over last 100 years real estate would
have been the top asset class um and
it's a top asset class
because you can you can lever it
and you can pay back the the debt in
money that's being devalued over time
and and so you you take on debts then
use the system to be able to pay back
debt and cheaper dollars tomorrow and
your asset price rises
now and then if you own 10 houses and
your neighbor owns one you're richer
than your neighbor because now you can
rent those uh rents go up and again with
along with inflation as well if you own
100 houses you you're wealthier if
you're blackstone in competing against
private buyers
in the real estate market you own more
of the wealth
so so
that system and then if you don't own it
uh houses obviously you're a slave to
that to that system working harder and
harder as your rent food everything else
is is going up so you can see the
example i'm making through real estate
alone that that's been the top
performing asset class over the last
call 100 years
um next would be
equities but all of those all of those
assets are in the existing system and
being priced in
devaluing dollars and that's not the
that's one risk those dollars being
devalued and if you think that that's
the only risk then
continue to own
predominantly real estate equities and
everything else because you'll have some
sort of safety in that but that's not
the primary risk that's not the only
risk the other risk is the system
collapse
um
and bitcoin protects against both both
of those risks um and today it would be
hard to see uh because you don't have
you know uh in bitcoin there's two
network effects one of the store of
value that is growing the primary kind
of layer one which be it would be like
investing in the internet itself tcpip
um and then layer two on lightning and
such and would pop you know a lot about
this but but today if if you pre if you
project if you said today where we are
people say well i can't use bitcoin as
as a currency in most places it's just
hard or hard to use as a currency
but remember what we do what all
businesses do we we project our current
reality forward
thinking we're projecting the future
instead of projecting the trend of
technology forward and what that will
mean
and what that means and what's happening
on layer two and bitcoin is you have two
network effects feeding back against
each other and it will and i i think it
will highly likely to become a currency
that you can use and this and the best
store of value so in in in
first world countries we don't see that
because we've had a system that it
operates pretty fairly for a lot of
years
but if you're in a third world country
like el salvador and you don't
even the bitcoin is upwardly volatile
it is less risk to use that as a
currency than an exit the existing
currency and so what you see is
lots of other countries starting to use
this as a medium exchange as well
got it and so when you start to think
about the lightning network i know that
you've spent some time on this i've seen
you tweet about it a couple of times
over the last couple of weeks um what's
your assessment as to where we are today
and uh kind of why are you so excited
about that uh you know i'm very very
bullish i feel like i'm so biased at
this point that i can't even
be honest about my analysis anymore so
maybe you can uh kind of explain to
folks why you're so bullish on it
well just
it's probably easier just to use a
specific example and think about what
might happen in the market what we do
what's what you might do if you're a
business
visa charges between two and a half and
three and a half percent to businesses
lightning is
almost zero
it so that means as a business you could
increase your net profits or you could
increase your profits by by that amount
um
and when businesses are operating on the
low margins that's a big amount to be
able to increase their their their
profits by so businesses are going to
enable this and they're going to
encourage users to use more and they'll
give discounts likely to users who use
more of lightning network and once that
starts what you see mcdonald's in el
salvador you see starbucks and el
salvador are using lightning
so
in an instant it's available in el
salvador what do you think is going to
happen
next when mcdonald's looks across the
world at their other stores and where
else can we implement this because we
make more money
and if we make more money and all
businesses are starting to make more
money as a result
then competition will come to lower
prices again and
and again technology that empowers
people and lowers the price of things
is very very hard to stop
and i the question is why would you want
to stop it
because you're saying
we can't stop we we won't allow this
because it helps people
and so
so as a result of that you're going to
see this this explode in um i think
around the world because there's an
incentive structure that helps people
when you start to think about
the adoption of this asset we've
recently seen el salvador obviously make
it legal tender
to me
we've seen something similar maybe in
the past where if you look at like m
pesa and mobile banking there's a number
of countries in africa that seem to have
leapfrogged the united states right you
talked a little bit earlier about the
developed nation
really having
almost a privilege right that we have
something that works good enough and so
we don't think about the cutting-edge
technology and the need to be innovative
and adopt that is that what's happening
here is these developed nations
basically are saying hey we're so far
behind and the only way that we can make
progress is to kind of make this giant
leap forward this is the best technology
today and so let's go ahead and kind of
make a bet on it or is there something
else at play with with the developed
nation uh developing nations whether
it's el salvador um somewhere like in
nigeria
that seem to really be embracing this
technology
i think a little bit of both but uh but
um but
again going back to a business example
and i'll use myself one of my my first
company um
yahoo and a bunch of different media
companies yahoo specifically it was the
kind of tech enabled but it charges a
minimum of 5000 a month for for
advertising google was free
so where did we build our resources we
built it to google
and besides yahoo
the the rest of the the infrastructure
look like large
media empires that we couldn't afford to
advertise on so what ended up happening
is what
the
the smaller companies
the long tail of all of the small
companies drive adoption first same
thing happened in the internet in
general it's a small companies that
drive adoption not the big big ones
because the big ones have
access and they have privileged access
already they don't see it
same thing happened on amazon um it
wasn't all of the all of the stores all
the
merchants that were in walmart that went
on amazon it was all the merchants that
didn't have access to walmart
so what you can see in that is when you
have a technology that empowers people
what happens is the people that are most
underprivileged or who or who don't have
access to the existing system
use it first and they create a
network effect that more and more users
and they create more and more value in
that network as they use it
which brings on bigger and bigger
players all the time if you looked at
what was happening on on on bitcoin and
lightning that's exactly what's
happening and you could just abstract
instead of
just just happening at the company or
personal level it's now happening at a
country level as well
i don't think i've ever asked you this
so i apologize so i'm putting on the
spot a little bit but how do you think
about um if you have you know one dollar
or one unit of fiat currency uh the
opportunity to buy bitcoin versus uh
invest in the infrastructure of bitcoin
and kind of what's being built around it
versus let's say equity or real estate
do you have some sort of like mental
framework uh in terms of almost like a
portfolio construction strategy uh or do
you think that we've gotten to the point
where certain parts of this are so
de-risked that you feel more comfortable
having like over-exposure compared to
like the traditional frameworks
yeah and i i'll answer that but i want
to be careful in the answer because
because
because everybody's position is
different right and and i want to i
don't want somebody to just copy my
position because because
again if bitcoin went to zero
i would be i'd be fine if the rest of my
portfolio went to zero i would be fine
so so
so i kind of have this barbell strategy
um that that i realized what
if i looked at the probabilities of
what's going to happen the probabilities
are or the higher probability is this
government's going to pretend to ease or
try to signal easing and they're not
going to be able to and they're going to
print a bunch bunch more money and
that's going to continue
and society is going to if you think
about what what people are talking about
today which is kind of two orders away
from the primary thing that we're
talking about
and and everybody's
kind of what you see is almost kind of
this early versions of societal collapse
happening as a result of this
um
that's going to continue and so so in
that i think bitcoin is a very very safe
bat and and something i have to have for
my family because i can get on a plane
go
go anywhere
um as far as
uh lightning layer two
um in in some of the
if if i said bitcoin was investing in
the tcp the uh internet lightning layer
two is kind of the company formation on
top on
i think there's going to be tons of
opportunity in that i know you're in
strike i think there's some incredible
opportunity in that
like like investing in
amazon or google in
in the year 2000 something
something like that
the um that's kind of bitcoin i do uh
i do own some real estate i own a real
estate technology company i own
many many technology companies or
quite a large investor in many different
technology companies is when i look at
the when i look at all of these things i
look at where can
where is technology
able to provide a structural change to
the market that helps people and what
did what what entrepreneurs so bitcoin
is obviously a giant thesis in that
because because that's one of those
areas but there's lots of other areas
like that um agriculture would be uh be
one that's that's going under undergoing
a structural change because of
technology and the winners of that are
going to provide value no matter what so
i typically look at
um that kind of real estate technology
companies uh and and and bitcoin would
be how i'd look at my assets
what uh what questions joe john do you
guys have
uh mine would be around el salvador so
we saw that they made uh bitcoin legal
tender went live i believe last week
and a lot of the people that we talk to
here especially in kind of the the us
and other americans i think sometimes
take kind of our strong financial system
for granted so i'm curious uh jeff kind
of what your thoughts are on on the
impact that bitcoin could potentially
have in el salvador and how you think uh
kind of the technology and the network
uh and how it may play a role in the
future of uh kind of not only uh the
economic piece of their country but also
the individuals that live there
yeah and and i'll just build on that
other
comment i made before early uh early um
users of a new network that's gaining
contraction like this
are most enriched by it um an example
would be
early instagram stars right and it's not
a really good example for bitcoin but it
but but if you're early on a network
that's exploding and delivering more and
more value
you ride that value and you and and so
try to be try to become an instagram
star today or a youtube star today you
have a lot more work you have to deliver
a lot more value than somebody who wrote
the network up in the beginning
and so so just like
um just just like an existing system the
existing system el salvador it was in
um we look at crime rates we look at
everything else and we forget to realize
that those crime rates are
a result
of having an economic system that is
impoverishes most people and so people
turn to crime as a result of that
um having a system like this
empowers people
and prices come down
prices come down as a result and those
people prices coming down or bitcoin
value going up is the same thing they
will be
um el salvador
could look like the new g7 going forward
if
if people don't move as fast if other
countries don't move as fast so the
advantage moves
to the the person without all the legacy
in the country
without all the legacy infrastructure
just like the advantage to move to
netflix without the legacy
infrastructure or blockbuster and that
that promises
for for
el salvadorian people
that that promise is an incredible
promise um
there's going to be it's not going to be
a straight line there's going to be a
lot of
noise along this there's going to be a
lot of people that are going to discount
how big that is but it's a huge it's
monumental
change and what they what what's
possible in their uh in el salvador
john what do you think yeah jeff thank
you for doing this um i actually just
ordered your book while you were talking
i'm excited
wow
um i am curious what you think about
like inflation as a whole for our
economy in the united states right so
what are the solutions that the people
in place can put
uh is it adopt bitcoin is is the
infrastructure that we have right now a
blocker to adoption like what can they
do to kind of help fight inflation as a
whole
so
so so remember if you don't have
inflation
you're going to have a complete collapse
so so well it's easy to talk about that
what is the fed doing they're creating
this worse think about think about it
this here's a
20 years ago
you might have been able to transition
easier um
and and instead interest rates went down
to try to grow interest rates went down
to try to grow creating bubbles
everywhere dot com christ dot com
market
housing crisis everything else instead
of those bubbles going away
we papered over those with more and more
printing
so now if you think about these two
trends
way back here
when technology was only kind of
disinflationary call it at one percent a
year
it
it looked like we were still operating
in the old environment like blockbuster
thinking netflix is not
but now as we move further and further
down this trend technology might might
be producing prices at negative four
percent per year
but we measure inflation off zero
and we're further and further away so it
takes
an exponential amount of debt and money
printing
to combat an exponential
exponential technology moving the other
way
and that
drop now from
a hype that's unimaginable is what is
what central bankers are trying to stop
but i don't know if they're going to be
i don't believe they're going to be able
to stop in your last segment you talked
about inflation and inflation
expectations look at bond yields look at
long-term bond yields the bond yields
where the majority of the market is are
expecting deflation
and and
and so
and
and and so when
when markets turn and they move to
deflation
or disinflation
what what people will look at and
they'll say
see the fed was right they didn't do
enough they need to print more
unaware that that that same thing is
driving the societal collapse
and so so expect
like in that environment you're going to
have a lot of head fakes
back and forth but again the system
can't change the system there's nothing
that they can
do no matter who's in power and no
matter who's elected it's just all noise
um
what should happen what could happen is
if and you're starting to see this
politicians are starting to understand
this some politicians are starting to
as understand this
um and
and and starting to say we need to be on
bitcoin we need to
drive our financial system into
something that can make this tran uh
transition and so so i would encourage
that but i think you're going to see it
anyways because it's going to if it
doesn't happen at a federal level it'll
happen at the state level and you're
starting to see that
nice
it it's incredible um how quickly people
are getting a crash course in economics
inflation deflation monetary policy
fiscal policy um
and
i try to wonder
uh
without the bias of hindsight how many
people knew in other places this stuff
and the quest and the answer's probably
not many and they kind of got a crash
course and the example that i always use
uh with people is if i ask somebody here
in the u.s or in canada you know what's
the exchange rate of x currency to
another they got no clue right if i said
you know what's the what's the u.s euro
exchange rate personal street bank
what's an exchange rate right you go to
uh venezuela everyone knows the exchange
rate
right and so i do think that there is
this element of um the faster people can
learn uh at least the basics you have to
be an expert you have to try to become
an economist but just the basics alone
it gives you a little bit more foresight
into what's happening and it allows you
to uh you know just kind of make
decisions where you don't even have to
be 100 right i think if you're just
directionally making good decisions uh
you're going to end up much much better
than if you simply say i don't know what
any of this means i'm just going to sit
here hold dollars and you know cross my
fingers hope that it works
on that and i think this is what your
show does is really really great and a
whole bunch of people in the bitcoin
community because to understand bitcoin
you have to understand game theory you
have to understand a whole bunch of
different pieces economics
but if you just simplify this really
simplify this
why do we believe we need inflation
so inflation is a hidden tax
um and we say we need inflation at two
percent why
so so we must have a hidden tax
that our money loses value at two
percent a year
um
why
is that required for productive society
um so if you ask some of these questions
to anybody
there it's easier for them to see it
or or how about this
what is more believable
especially is all around it every day
technology makes your life more
efficient essentially saves you time
gives you more for less
and prices drop as a result or
[Music]
prices need to rise forever and we're
going to manipulate money to make that
happen like what
if you just ask some really logical
questions
it starts to break people's
kind of
mental models of what they formally
believed that had to be true
and and what ends up happening is we
build our foundation of knowledge and
then we build on top of that foundation
so we don't question that foundation
very often and inflation is one of those
foundational knowledges that we don't
pieces of foundational knowledge that no
one is even questioned
and so why
why can't a productive society work
um without stealing money at two percent
a year i just don't get it
i uh my brothers will laugh when they
hear me say this because i say all the
time you can't be rational in an
irrational world
right you can't ask serious important
questions like that you just gotta go
with the flow what are you doing trying
to actually uh be smart when everyone
else is being stupid that's uh that's
illegal now um tell us about uh the book
real quick before we let you go i know
we're running out of time but uh tell us
a little bit about uh the book and the
process in terms of writing it uh it's
fantastic now john is going to read it
as well he gives a little book review
maybe next week
but tell us a little bit about it
i you know i i i again it turned out to
be great it turned into a bestseller
around the world but i didn't write it
for that i wrote it because of what
we're talking about now i looked at my
kids and i said they're not going to
grow up in the same world that i'm in i
could not understand why everything
around us i sit at the intersection of
technology i sit at the intersection i'm
on robotics companies boards i'm on
ai company boards i see how fast this is
moving into every part of our society
and it didn't make sense to me that uh
that what was
that prices were rising in that until i
investigated and realized wow we've
created 185 trillion dollars of debt to
the world globally to to grow the
economy by 46 trillion in 20 years
and and that's why that's the smoking
gun that it's getting
in that and that has to get worse and
worse and worse in the existing system
and so as i started to see that i
started to see
this is a this is really a phase
transition of of this is going to res
that stat is going to be reset one way
or another um however
throughout history how are those
typically handled and they're handled
through revolution and war as people
turn people against other people and to
get elected and then once they're
elected they need to create a bigger
enemy which is outside of the border so
that's how it's traditionally been
handled throughout human history
and i didn't want that to happen with my
kids so as i investigated this and
everything else i said i have to write
this book
and
there's there's literally one paragraph
about bitcoin at the end of the book
it's not a bitcoin book it's a where are
we going book
um but then as a deeper and deeper i
believe that bitcoin is the only
transmission mechanism
that doesn't have that negative out that
that negative outcome so so
so
that's why i wrote i wrote the book for
my kids
there are multiple people in the chat
right now saying how the hell did i not
know about this guy beforehand we are
completely aligned in the way that we
think about the world so i think i think
your message is definitely resonating
i'm putting right now in uh
in the chat people can go and follow you
on twitter um is there anywhere else
that you want to send them i put the the
link to the book and then obviously uh
taft folks go ahead and follow you on
twitter anywhere else
that's probably great that's why that's
perfect
all right my friend listen thank you so
much for taking the time to do this i i
i know that you just been hammering away
at the message and uh people are
listening so keep going i i really
enjoyed the book i uh could not
recommend it more to folks uh so if
you're watching this go go buy it and
then give jeff a follow on twitter he
actually is uh what i call a reasonable
bitcoiner in that uh he says smart
things and doesn't [ __ ] post at all
which i can appreciate as well you know
sometimes i get a little [ __ ] posted in
there myself
all right buddy sounds good thanks so
much for doing this we'll talk soon okay
see ya bye thanks jeff what's up guys
bang bang thanks so much for watching
the best business show today if we're
gonna be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you 10 in bitcoin
for free it's that simple head on over
to sofi.com to get started today thanks
so much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]
you